welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
out of the scrolls are among us is it
you or could it be you either way with
secret Invasion on the way we here at
new rock stars thought that we should
prepare you all for an Invasion of the
Body Snatchers by telling you everything
that you need to know about the Scrolls
in the MCU while also giving you a list
of the most devastating MCU characters
if the Scrolls could ever impersonate to
take over the entire planet let's go
everybody and hey this video is brought
to you by Squarespace more on them later
but like always do not forget to hit up
nerd riot.shop so that you can get you
an amazing new nerd shirt on your body
we have some incredible new Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 designs these are some
of my favorite shirts that we've ever
made alright so the scrolls are of
course a race of shape-shifting aliens
in a seemingly never-ending War With The
Intergalactic Blue Man Group known as
the cree Empire and the cree scroll War
has been a conflict that has been going
on for thousands of years in the MCU
mostly because the cree have
historically been extremely aggressive
bullies in the Galaxy bent on gobbling
up as many planets as they can into
their empire and the Scrolls just aren't
having it but though this war has been
waging for a millennium in the
background of the MCU we didn't get our
first look at the scroll race until
Captain Marvel's first movie before then
our only hint Epi Scrolls existence in
the overall MCU came in Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 1. when the words Excelsior
are written in the scroll language as
Rocket Raccoon roasts Stan the Man one
of my favorite Easter eggs from that
movie R.I.P Stan when we first meet the
Scrolls in Captain Marvel they were
portrayed as refugees led by Ben
Mendelson's Talos alongside his wife
Soren Talos used to be a commander in
the scroll Army in the overall battle
against the greedy creedy but after the
cree destroyed the scroll Homeworld of
scrollos Talos Soren and their daughter
Gaia and a bunch of other scroll
survivors were forced to flee the Wrath
of the cree Empire we actually first
meet Gaia as a shape-shifting 90s kid in
Captain Marvel but by secret Invasion
she will be an adult played by Game of
Thrones Emilia Clarke however secret
Invasion seems like it is telling us
that Talos and Soren's group peaceful
refugees might not be the only flavor of
Survivor in town anymore as the coming
of the scroll graphic to the planet
Earth alongside his own separate group
of scroll refugees seems to hint that
there are Scrolls that are still ready
to wage full-on war for the overall good
of their people and it seems like Earth
just might hold some valuable resources
for graphic to utilize so that the
scroll race can get the revenge on the
cree Empire for their genocidal behavior
on scrollos a lot of people died on that
planet but regardless of what Graphics
motivation for his band of scroll
refugees actually is there is no denying
that secret Invasion will see graphic
and Talos butting heads as they fight
over Earth's territory in Disguise but
speaking of scroll disguises let's talk
about the squirrel's ability to
shape-shift and how it seems to work in
the MCU the Captain Marvel movie
established that in order for a scroll
to impersonate someone they need to
visually see their physical form first
but when they do this they are somehow
able to copy the subject absolutely
perfectly down to the very composition
of their DNA which is very impressive
and I feel like this is best exemplified
in the MCU when we get that first person
view of of Talos absorbing the photonic
information of that Surfer lady into his
eyeballs which then kickstarts his
transformation into her physical form
but notice something super important
here as Talos transforms there are two
components to the scroll transformation
the transformation of the scroll body
and the transformation of the scroll
close they transform differently in the
MCU with talos's clothes turning into a
weird purple energy that is then
absorbed into this purple Crystal on his
left shoulder before then manifesting
into the surfer's suit this implies to
me that these purple crystals on these
scroll uniform are what the squirrels
wear in order for their clothes on their
transforming bodies to transform with
them but what about their green physical
bodies underneath their special clothes
how do they work well we learned from an
autopsy of one of talos's homies in
Captain Marvel that a major factor that
contributes to these thrall ability to
transform is the scroll atomic structure
itself all life on Earth is carbon based
not this guy whatever he runs on it's
not on the periodic table that's right
everybody while human being things are
made up of carbon and other elements on
our Periodic Table of known elements
scroll bodies are made up of matter that
ain't nobody on Earth has seen before
however if I were to take a stab of a
guess I would say that there is a chance
that this mysterious matter that makes
up a scroll could be linked to Marvel
and Howard Stark's favorite Tesseract
itself because remember in Iron Man 2
when Tony Stark discovers it creates a
new element that nobody has seen before
using Howard Stark's work on the
Tesseract I have a feeling that this new
element is the very same element that
powers the scroll race and makes their
biology unique an element links to the
blue cosmic energy of the Tesseract and
by extension vibranium the scroll body
is probably able to morph itself a lot
like the vibranium of wakanda can you
know like the wakandan kimoyo beads or
shuri's holographic vehicle interface or
even Tony Stark's Infinity War suit and
the reason why I'm making this
connection to vibranium is because we
learn in the killmonger episode of what
if the blue energy within vibranium is
closely connected to the blue cosmic
energy of the Tesseract as well because
the atomic structure of killmonger's
ring in that episode matches that of the
new element that Howard Stark Left
Behind for his nosy ass nerd of a son to
discover later on in life when he was
having some problems in Iron Man 2. this
is very depressed man this is
significant because it brings us to our
next major scroll fact Scrolls can act
actually be detected in the MCU much
like they can in the comics in fact
there is already a major scroll detector
invented in the MCU that Nick Fury
totally forgot to bring with him for
secret Invasion like a dingus like how
are you going to fight Scrolls and
forget Shield's ultimate secret weapon
against the skrull empire Goose the
flarken the meowing Terror of the scroll
race and the best Kitty of all time look
at him he's so cute in Captain Marvel it
appears that goose has been able to spot
squirrels in Disguise merely by their
Cosmic scent but look we're gonna get
back to the video in just one second but
I've got to tell you guys about
Squarespace not only are they making it
possible for me to do this video but
they could be making it possible for you
to do whatever you want to do online
that's because Squarespace makes it easy
to make an awesome website that lets you
engage with your audience and sell
anything that you need your products
content you create and even your time
Squarespace is an all-in-one platform
for building your brand and growing your
business online if you're into making
videos Squarespace can help you create
Pro level videos effortlessly the
Squarespace video studio app will help
you make and share engaging videos to
tell your story grow your audience and
drive sales but hey maybe videos aren't
your thing because you're more of a
social media bug you can display posts
from any profile you want on your
website and automatically push website
content to your favorite social media
channels to your followers can share it
too no matter what you're doing
squarespace's analytic tools will help
you learn where your traffic and sales
are coming from so that you can improve
your website and build a marketing
strategy based either on your top
keywords or most popular products and
content head to squarespace.com for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com new
rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or domain and
since Captain Marvel showed us that
goose had a major appetite for the
Tesseract itself even sort of seemingly
leading Captain Marvel's group to the
Tesseract after following its scent when
they first arrive on the ship and I
freaking love how groose even appears to
try to open up the Tesseract like it was
a closed can of tuna something tells me
that they tend to called flirt and race
might be related to those tentacle
monsters from what if because they seem
to have a very similar appetite for
tesseracts but anyways the important
Point here is if you scroll Atomic
makeup is linked to Marvel's mysterious
Tesseract then he goes theoretically
wouldn't be the only tool in the MCU
that could find Scrolls in hiding
because there could be a chance that
riri's vibranium detecting machine could
eventually be evolved to detract the
scent of Scrolls as well but anyways
moving on here is an important point to
note about scroll shape-shifting even
though Scrolls can take the form of
anyone that they see they don't
automatically absorb their memory
instead the Scrolls have developed a
type of technology that allows them to
scan the minds of the people that they
capture and then download that
information into these little purple
Crystal thingies that look very similar
to the crystals that they have on their
shoulder pads this could explain why we
see that massive room of people being
stored in some type of alien containment
in the secret Invasion trailers each of
those people who represent a human being
that one of graphic Scrolls is
impersonating at the moment but those
human beings are still being kept alive
and still storage just in case one of
those Scrolls need to update themselves
on the role that they're playing or pass
off that role to somebody else like this
piece of technology that the Scrolls use
to invade the privacy of people's entire
lives is precisely what makes them so
dangerous you know in combination with
the whole shape-shifting thing so thank
God Nick Fury was not on the planet
Earth this entire time apparently
because if there is any human being that
Graphics invading Scrolls would want to
kidnap and replace first it is none
other than Nicholas J Fury the man with
one eye and multiple very powerful
friends like Nick Fury has spent his
entire career Gathering the most
sensitive information in the world both
as Shield's best international spy on
the field and as a scientist as you
spend the most influential parts of his
career as a head researcher on the
potential for Tesseract dark energy as a
weapon like ever since the events of
Captain Marvel radically changed Nick
Fury's understanding of Earth's threats
in the 90s Fury has made it his life's
mission to be one of the foremost
experts on extraterrestrial threats to
Earth because as we learned in the
secret Invasion trailers Fury has always
been preparing for an inevitable war
with outside forces in the universe it's
basically why Nick Fury assembled The
Avengers in the first place while also
trying to replicate those Tesseract
Hydro weapons that Zola and Red Skull
made back in World War II Behind The
Avengers backs because as much as Nick
Fury believed in his Avengers project he
trusted in the power of the Tesseract
just as much and that's what phase two
of his project was with Nick Fury's
extensive knowledge of pretty much
everything that is going on on Earth at
all times over the last few decades I
can definitely see why Fury could have
voluntarily takened himself off the grid
for a little while nefery's brain just
being on Earth is a massive security
risk with the existence of these scroll
people and if we're talking Nick Fury
then of course the next best Target to
chase if you can't get at Nick Fury is
of course Maria Hill Nick Fury's right
hand woman and probably the closest
human that Fury could probably call a
friend in confidante while definitely
not as filled with top secret info
information as her older boss Nick Fury
being a high-level Shield agent and an
Avengers Ally definitely gives a scroll
access to a lot of extremely damaging
secrets to humanity if the skrulls ever
got a hold of Maria but luckily the role
of Maria Hill currently belongs to
talos's lovely green wife Soren so that
person is taken but who else could be a
major liability for the planet Earth if
they ever got their brains downloaded
let's have a think together speculation
Nation because if I'm in the invading
scroll Army I'm gonna go for the most
powerful and influential people on the
planet and that definitely includes the
American government with the most
vulnerable person in America obviously
being the president of the United States
who at the start of secret invasion is
president ritzen but whose motorcade
seems to be under attack in the secret
Invasion promo material so things don't
appear to end well for president ritzen
in that series especially since we
already know that Thunderbolt Ross will
apparently be the president by the start
of the events of Captain America new
world order so pretty much anyone within
president Ross or ritzen's cabinet
minutes and inner circles could
potentially be a scroll even Betty Ross
who we know will be making an appearance
in Captain America 4 as well after to
live Tyler's last appearance in 2008's
Incredible Hulk but in regards to other
important American political figures we
also have Roadie who apparently seems to
have some type of political position in
the secret Invasion series and could
potentially have a very close
relationship with Thunderbolt Ross as
we've seen in previous movies like
Infinity war and with rhodey's extensive
knowledge of Tony Stark's Ark reactor
technology and everything Iron Man Left
Behind after his death like any of the
senators from Falcon and the Winter
Soldier dodc agent Cleary or anyone from
the Superhuman law division in regards
to the Avengers the one of the best
people to actually take over is the form
of Steve Rogers because everyone in the
world is missing Steve Rogers a lot and
probably don't 100 like Sam Wilson as
the new Captain America and of course
Helen Cho from Avengers 2 would be
another great person for the Scrolls to
take over given her extensive science
knowledge as well as her closeness with
everyone on that team all the core
members in regards to the shield
organization Nick Fury Maria Hill
Cameron Klein or any other Agents of
Shield or Goose would
ultimate in to get anywhere in that
organization as long as you got one
person in Shield you can slowly make
your way to the top regardless of the
people of Project Pegasus who are
working on the science of the Tesseract
to make weapons Eric selvic is your best
bet because he knows a whole lot about
that damn Cube and of course again goose
is one of the best life forms to
impersonate because no one has got a
question what a cat is doing in a room
at any time in regards to the CIA of
course of Contessa Valentina Allegre de
Fontaine is the number one gal to get at
but we also have the power broker or AKA
Sharon Carter who used to work for the
CIA as well both her past as a CIA agent
and her current role as the power broker
are very influential factors for the
Scrolls who want to take her over and of
course we also have agent madani from
The Punisher series who also works for
the CIA in regards to Russia I believe
that Molina from Black Widow is probably
the best bet as she herself has unlocked
the ability to control human Free Will
which something that the Scrolls will
really love in their back pocket but
also Taskmaster taskmaster's memories
are probably something that is very
important to the scroll Empire and of
course Mr Zemo himself with his past
knowledge of that red winter soldier
book could probably be a huge ass into
the Scrolls because then they could
probably control the Winter Soldier but
speaking of his emo let's talk about
Hydro because I believe that the best
person for a scroll to impersonate now
is of course Mitchell Carson who we last
saw in Ant-Man 1 trying to rebuild the
Hydra organization with pin particles
and of course we cannot forget about
ghost because she herself has run a lot
of missions for Hydra slash Shield while
she was working for them so she's got a
lot of Intel in her very crazy brain in
regards to the nation of wakanda the
best people to take over are of course
Nakia wakabi any of the war dogs hiding
in the world in Okoye in the midline
Angels like any of those could
potentially get you to either shuri or
King umbaku and of course also Everett
Ross who is a liaison between wakanda
and the white world and of course we
also have the 10 Rings anybody who is
either close to shiling or anybody who
went to talo itself could be a huge
threat to the 10 rings and talo And in
regards to the Stark Foundation which is
a powerful organization on Earth pepper
pots happy Hogan or Morgan Stark would
be the Best Bets there and to best
infiltrate sword director Hayward who is
currently arrested after your vegetable
on division still has a lot of really
important information in his brain that
these Scrolls could use to potentially
take over Damocles base that we see in
the Marvel's trailer and also Monica
Rambo would be a massive get for them as
she is very involved with sword as well
but two of the worst people for these
Scrolls to ever download the information
of their brains are of course Wanda
maximoff and Agatha Harkness the dark
holders of the MCU because as of the
events of Doctor Strange 2 all the dark
holes in the Multiverse have been
destroyed however there are still copies
of the dark hold within Agatha and
Wanda's brains so they better stay far
away from the Scrolls as possible but in
terms of the worlds of sorcerers in
general we have Christine Palmer who is
someone that doctor strange will
literally go insane over if anything
happened to her and we also have Madison
who is close to Wong America Chavez and
her perspective of the Multiverse could
potentially be really damaging
information for the Scrolls to have and
also why Longs fall in love Sarah from
Multiverse of Madness I feel like if I
scroll impersonated Sarah she could
potentially manipulate Wong whoever the
hell they she wanted in regards to
Asgard Valkyrie Korg and Lady stiff are
probably the best three points of
contact there and finally in the world
of street level Street crime Kingpin
Vanessa Fisk Kate Bishop's mom Eleanor
Bishop Luke Cage or tinkerer's crew from
Spider-Man homecoming could be the best
sources to take over all of Street crime
in the MCU and of course there are just
generally people on the planet that just
know too much the pins who know all
about pimparticle technology Doctor
Strange who just knows too much about
magic Advanced idea mechanics and of
course again Nick Fury whose entire job
it is to know too damn much but that is
just my list of everyone in the MCU that
could be the most devastating if they
were ever taken over by a scroll who do
you think would be the most crucial
captures for the scroll Empire let us
know in the comment section below but
anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
Master retainment on Twitter if you want
to see me tweet some weird shits and
really fun theories the most importantly
you can follow new Yorkshire is where we
are on social medias but again thank you
guys so much for watching this video I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye
[Music]